what's up with you and ddg [__] you guys
have like a whole [__] album pretty
much done right
[Music]
oh [__] I don't know
I ain't [__] I don't know you know that
[__] right now no idea I'm doing this
[__] right here yo uh question what
happened with that did Ruby Rose prop
you up like this all or did you prop
Ruby Rose up to send out all these
[__] screenshots
were you were you with her that day yeah
tell her to tell her okay I'm talking to
everybody what do you mean I'm just
curious were you like yes screenshot
that [__] and send it out to the world
[__] him girl did you say that no I was
like if it was me no okay can you shut
the [__] up I'm on your business
if it was you there what'd you tell her
if it was me I like I would let them all
know that he cab and then he I don't
know but I'm like what would you do she
said I was already thinking about it so
you kind of pushed her over the ledge
you were like I wouldn't care I don't
care dude I don't have no confirmation
anything to whoever in the message what
ddg's your friend that's what I would
make him your friend in some type of way
everybody my friend but it's like what
you mean everybody I can't control a
grown woman to do something I'm not
taking her phone because right she
pushed her how did I push she's so dumb
as [__]
you sound dumb as far
are you friends with Ruby hey if I get
to blame my friends a lot of this time
you're going like [__] shut the [__] up
you did it cause you wanted to do it
right what the [__]
if what's the uh not if it was one of
your your friends that you would listen
what are you talking she was gonna do it
me with me there or with me they're not
there like what do you mean the [__] you
just happened to be there she was giving
her like moral support is that the crime
scene yeah she didn't do anything safe
to say if you guys go on another double
date with ddg in his life
it'll just be weird what if you guys go
on a double date with uh with I don't
think that'll probably ever happen again
yeah probably not weird
[__] yeah we know we know that's that's
the bad part that's the bad part I don't
think I don't think you guys are gonna
go to The Little Mermaids The Little
Mermaid Premiere you guys will not be
getting an invite too I don't think so
though it'll be all right